[Music]
your mutant son of a [ __ ] you want me
to kill yours
very clever what kind the 4s kind the
human time
it's name is Ren for you but the way you
just sit in the corner and brood I made
a drink alone good yeah good no one else
hesitated to comment on the quality of
my performance except for you come on oh
it could be your Barker spreading the
tales of Geralt of Rivia the butcher of
Barbican come here yeah whatever hop up
there with you is just I'm not really
wearing the right kind of saturation oh
don't leave me again blessed silence
this is the part where we escape this is
the pollak else I've made you famous
where sure
by rights I should be climbing temps
scent of all your coin but instead what
I'm asking for is a teeny teeny weeny
little bit [ __ ] off world blush with a
single comely smile and rivers of the
sweetest of drinks from the rarest of
scary face no Lord in his right mind
will come close if you're standing next
to me with a puss like that
Oh upon second thoughts I want to lay
off the sintra name clear head would be
best
where the [ __ ] are my clothes yes ma'am
uh well they were sort of covered in
sulky more guts so I said no way to be
washed anyway you're not going tonight
as a witch
she's not for living in a husband shut
up oh you want something how are you
doing I hear you ask
I didn't well the chin she might have a
desk you take back that bit about my
felling let spike take it back and then
you can have your Ginny gin gin that
girl no no you horses ah this is a
little tight I believe I sized you up
quite right
are you perhaps short of a marble you
have to go in there don't you I
recognize the look I know how you feel
you're making me uncomfortable
this woman just killed him out with the
bare hands for trying to steal your
horse maybe she'll make a better travel
companion then why is it whenever I find
myself in a pond of [ __ ] these days it's
you shoveling it it's not the child
surprise if life could give me one
blessing it would be to take you off my
hands